auslandseinsatz kombinieren von 31 in
der stärke von 302 mann und eine
abordnung der kameradschaft zu findet
zur feierlichen verabschiedung
angetreten herr major danke mit dem
facebook hat
ich wünsche ihnen für die nächsten sechs
monate dass ihre erwartungen und die
hohe aufgabe der sie für österreich für
die internationale staatengemeinschaft
und auch das bundesland kärnten
nachkommen dass sie diese nachkommen
können mit all ihrer kraft und unter
anwendung dessen wofür sie ausgebildet
worden sind
mein besonderer gruß gilt aber ihnen dem
zu verabschiedenden kontingent und ihren
angehörigen
dieses internationale engagement ist für
mich nicht nur ein deutliches zeichen
internationaler solidarität
es ist auch der untrügliche pws für ein
funktionierendes österreichisches
bundesheer auf dass die bevölkerung zu
recht stolz sein kann